psychologue clinicienne chez human safe
depuis quatre ans louise prend en charge
des femmes victimes de violence aussi
bien physiques psychologiques sexuelles
ou encore économiques ou marseille
dispose d'une équipe complète elle
travaille sur les actions à mettre en
place pour aider les patients objectif
avoir une prise en charge globale
on a des rendez vous le matin on a les
rendez-vous l'après-midi et puis à
chaque fin de rendez-vous bas ont fait
une prise de notes sur ce qu'il s'est
passé on contacte les professionnels
extérieurs qu'il faut contacter pour
faire du lien et pour faire le meilleur
la meilleure prise en charge possible
pour la patiente et puis en fin de
journée on a un staff donc une réunion
d'équipé et ce qui est super du coup
c'est qu'on fait du pluridisciplinaire
et que ça nous permet d'échanger en
équipe 1 charnière juriste ma soeur lors
du premier confinement une hausse de
250% des femmes accueillies a été
constaté conséquence d'une période qui a
vu le nombre de violences augmentent et
ça a été un confinement assez costaud
parce que j'avais beaucoup plus de
personnes à prendre en charge et donc là
ça se reproduit à peu près aussi pendant
le 2ème confinement et c'est sur que
c'est pas la même inquiétude pour les
femmes quand disons qu'elles sont déjà
coincé chez elle avec un agresseur qui
refuse qu'elle partait qui veut
maintenir un contrôle sur elle à tout
prix mais quand ça en plus cette
inquiétude de peut voir peut-être
prendre une amende quand on sort etc
ça rajoute de l' angoisse dans ce
contexte le travail est plus intensif
pour la psychologue clinicienne de 27
ans mais louise n'en reste pas moins
passionné par son métier
j'ai la chance de faire quelque chose
qui me passionne à la fois bon c'est pas
c'était pas évident tous les jours quand
on avait ont multiplié les rendez-vous
téléphonique
avant en général j'en fais six par jour
pendant un confinement
j'en fais peut-être huit par jour aussi
à des moments parce que ben il faut il
faut multiplier les appels il faut pas
passer à côté dans le cas d'une personne
qui nous inquiète et pour lesquels il ya
peut-être une situation de danger
pour ce deuxième confinement louise
laisse le choix des consultations en
visioconférence ou en présentiel pour
rassurer ses patientes et ne pas être
juste une voix au téléphone